[Music]
bear is gone you know what else is gone
thank you sue what's happening
[Applause]
[Music]
do you see how fast he's running I've
never gotten that fast no one else
where is this samurai taking ours
already way past Danville and the only
thing out there is the flatlands and
what
[Music]
come on bear catcher
Barry
you came back to me
Oh
[Music]
Sammy Ryan said its purpose as in 12th
century feudal Japan time when the
military class was powerful the
execution methodical like ours
well it worked the flash is back in
Central City
it appears things are going as planned
as if there were any doubt what's our
next step I'm thinking
everybody the flash is back holy crap we
have to break this down I'm making a
longer Easter Egg version of this but I
wanted to get a video out quickly in
case it took me a little bit longer so
if you're finding me for the first time
we're doing flash all season long be
sure to subscribe to get everything make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts
there's giveaway stuff at the end of the
video too the big thing here is that
Barry is effectively reborn now you
can't really die when your body's pure
energy so it's a little bit weird for
speedsters but the Speed Force is their
version of heaven so like that's where
versions of the reverse flash are
chilling right now so I guess if you
call this their version of flash rebirth
that you could call reverse flash coming
back reverse rebirth which would be fun
to freak out about when they announced
how they're bringing him back I know
there are a lot of theories about the
back half of the season but I'll hold
off on those until we get a little bit
more evidence the thing that I really
like about this episode is that they're
effectively wiping all the drama from
previous seasons clean Barry didn't
forget about all the stuff that happened
he still knows that his parents are dead
but he's let that baggage go if you're a
big fan of Avatar The Last Airbender
when he's trying to learn to control his
Avatar state - energy band Lobos
powerful form of bending he has to let
go of earthly attachment so Barry had to
learn to do that before he could come
back from the Speed Force although
there's a little bit of help from Cisco
there think of your attachments
[Music]
let the pure cosmic energy flow
[Applause]
[Music]
so the whole idea here is without
turning him into the three-eyed Raven
from Game of Thrones he exits the
speedforce with all this knowledge we
have this puzzle that we can decode when
I post my easter egg video later tonight
and you got your first teaser for the
thinker sort of controlling the samurai
here so we'll talk a little bit about
those characters their origins when I
post that video tonight but leave all
your questions in the comments
congratulations to the latest Justice
League ticket giveaway winner Adam Cho
Jess key please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details I'll announce a new
winner when I post my Easter eggs
so that should be up in a couple hours
for me posting this video you can click
here to watch that I'll update the link
as soon as I post it and you can click
here to rewatch the Justice League
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight